han pasado cinco días desde que el tifón
rai atravesará filipinas pero sus
consecuencias apenas empiezan a aflorar
aquí a la destrucción de cientos de
casas se suma la falta de ayuda
humanitaria algo que ha hecho que el
hambre se multiplique entre los
filipinos al igual que la desesperación
hide contento lukman la cna no va para
tema lanzaremos un llamado para que nos
lleguen al menos algunas pequeñas ayudas
y un ponen a gobierno ahora es el
momento en que necesitamos un gobierno
un gobierno que esté listo para
ayudarnos en nuestra situación actual a
la vayan a meter en íntegramente estamos
esperando a quien tenga un buen corazón
espero que nos ayudará toma la sala dame
la falta de electricidad e internet ha
hecho que tanto bancos como centros
hospitalarios estén inoperativos un
conjunto de factores que ha conllevado a
los primeros saqueos ya que las
autoridades adviertan que la espiral de
violencia pueda aumentar ante la
incertidumbre de haberlo perdido
prácticamente todo
morán no fono monógama y cuando el tifón
amainó baje a mi casa y luego escuché
algo que se rompió ese fue el momento en
que grite para que todos salieran
sintiendo que podría ocurrir un
deslizamiento de tierra al zleitni y
ahora me dejan ágata box al dabsh farm
hacen cuando cruzamos la calle y nos
quedamos en una farmacia vimos la
devastación de nuestra casa causada por
el deslizamiento de tierra de sapag
indicó wright dejó al menos 350
fallecidos y por lo menos 50
desaparecidos
convirtiéndose en uno de los tifones más
mortales en lo que va de año en
filipinas